The joe rogan experience,
like one of the first guys to go for the fucked up laugh,
like in the personal conversation,
like you just sitting there hanging out,
eating lunch,
and then you just,
you'll go for the,
but you don't mean that you're a really nice guy.
You know,
like I don't think people who aren't either immersed in the world of standup
comedy or know a lot of standup comics,
I don't think they appreciate that.
Right.
Yeah.
I think that to me it's about,
it's a gear.
You're commenting on normal conversation.
You're,
you're,
you're making fun of what a racist would say it and see.
Exactly.
You know,
and you're being racist to also being racist against was we are racist,
are we,
this is what we are.
Okay.
We are judgmental.
It's part of evolution.
We're constantly assessing our,
our environment.
And sometimes we know the shit you're not supposed to say.
So we say it because it's funny and it's also funny because there's some truth
to it,
right?
And it's fucked up.
There's some truth to it.
And God,
I wish it wasn't true.
I wish stereotypes weren't true.
Right.
We should talions.
I wish my own relatives were an apes.
I really wished they weren't savage,
untrustworthy apes,
but they are.
That's what they have to watch.
Fucking real housewives of New Jersey and we've see it's in that Italians.
We see my people,
my people are savages.
I wish that wasn't true,
but it's fucking true.
Yeah,
it's hard to,
it's hard to fight against the Italian stereotype because here's the problem
with Italians that there's many is that you're in Nabard with the fact that
you're Italian.
See,
you won't evolve.
Like every Italian guy.
You could meet some guy from fucking the prairie prairie land Midwest,
and if he's Italian,
he'll go and get the pasta fuzzy because they've watched the godfather and
they've watched sopranos and they want to sound like them because they want to
be Italian.
Whereas we're supposed to be all growing away from,
like you're saying,
the barbaric versions of ourselves should be in the past,
not perpetuated for generations.
I have friends that are back east friends.
I love him to death and I don't mind when they put it on.
I don't mind when they,
the AA.
Do the Italian talk,
a little piece of me dies.
Right,
right,
right.
I'm Irish.
Hey,
hey,
your mom is still making it goes goose Sheppey some of the comedy.
Giuseppe.
That's a big one.
Hey Giuseppe.
Very rare that that my Jewish friends call me Giuseppe if it might be already
when he was high,
but that's never seen an Italian guy have a solo fight.
It's always a fucking group jumps in.
Well,
there's a herd mentality involved and being proud of what patch of dirt you're
on.
Right.
That doesn't lend itself to courage.
Yes.
That's not the,
that's not the right mentality.
That's got the the rugged individual that takes on the group and wins.
No,
that's a fucking Bob.
You believe what this guy saying?
Oh,
it's Bobby.
Bobby's Bobby's wearing a wire the entire time.
Bob.
He's in the of the patrol car.
I was waiting to testify.
What the fuck Bobby with family over here.
Let this fucking shit go between us.
I was wondering why we call you to rat
and he was with Bobby to rat fucking cock sucker.
No,
he used to sit on my Mama's day.
Oblique Gaga.
Gulu shy.
I think about it.
What is,
who's the number one most famous gangsters of all time?
They're all Italian guys.
They'll braggadocious Gotti types or Al Capone.
I've got bone over here.
Jimmy Hoffa,
savages.
My people are criminal savages.
They make awesome food and know how to fuck.
That's it.
As girls.
Oh my God.
And your good luck.
I mean girl hot Italian girl hottest who can make really good food and likes to
fuck all the time.
She might beat you to death in your sleep.
Right?
And you don't mind.
It's worth it.
That's fucking crazy.
The cray.
This.
I love Italian church.
I grew up around dark,
dark Italian check I gave up on him last time.
Trigger Dude's like swing at me.
Rarely.
Yeah,
back in the back of the Boston days.
Right?
Like that's it.
I'm good.
Can't date anybody like me fucking animals.
Well that's it too.
You're not supposed to date within your own race.
That's proven.
I married,
well actually she's half Irish,
half Jewish,
but you got to,
you got to get a little way from mom.
It's a,
well the Irish were the most racist of all people because we're the fairest
skin.
We look down on everybody.
I don't think so.
Oh fuck man.
So really we came to America at the time when the Italians came at basically the
same time.
So when you go to the Bronx or Boston,
there's so race week,
they fucking hate each other and they hate everybody else because we were the
last ones to come over.
So everybody hated us.
We were the last ones to get jobs.
So we have to like the Irish were the last of the mean.
That's why we were,
is that first the first immigrants,
English,
the Dutch,
Dutch,
English,
the Scandinavians.
I know so little about the immigration of different cultures in this country.
Always know about my own family,
which was the great depression.
My grandparents came over during the depression.
Yeah,
there's a great book about Cornelius Vanderbilt and it kind of tracks New York
in the 18 hundreds.
And as the waves of people came over and,
uh,
it's really won the Pulitzer prize called the first tycoon.
My Grandmother,
the last tycoon,
my grandmother grew up in the depression.
She was kind of insane because of it.
And she used to like hide things all around the house.
Like she hide money in various spots in the house.
They didn't find it until after she died.
They went,
Shit,
did she hide?
Oh,
she had thousands of dollars walls.
But it's just,
but the idea was not just that she had money.
I mean she,
they were very poor.
Yeah.
But that she had money that she had squirreled away in to these weird spots all
over their house.
It was really weird.
I did you almost not find it before you,
well,
I didn't have anything to do with it.
His,
his children did the,
uh,
the,
my,
when my grandfather died,
I was over here and I think that's when they,
they started searching the house.
The people that were living in New Jersey,
they had it.
They had some idea that she was like,
Shit.
Oh No,
no,
they didn't know me.
She,
she had this,
she had had an aneurysm and she was sick for a long time because of it.
And um,
during that time,
my grandfather took care of her and my grandfather took care of her.
That's when I was staying with him.
And it was a very fascinating time in my life because,
um,
I had left Boston and I had moved to New York,
but I couldn't really afford to live in New York.
I didn't know I had hardly any money.
So I stated my grandfather,
who was living on North Ninth Street,
which was a really bad neighborhood in Newark,
the next door neighbor,
they got a battering ram broke down his fucking door because he's selling crack.
And he had like an Audi like next door.
Like this is fucking Newark,
New Jersey.
It's a shitty spot.
Oh Shit.
And my grandfather was taking care of my grandmother and it was just me and my
grandfather and my grandmother.
It was like one of the lowest points in my life.
I had just broken up with my girlfriend.
I had just torn my ACL and I knew that I needed surgery.
I just moved to New York.
I was completely,
totally broke and I was,
you know,
taking this big risk,
moving to New York.
I'd signed with Sussman and I want to remember that was trying to get my shit
together.
And my grandmother like Moans,
like she's,
she's hurt so bad she can't move.
She had an aneurysm 12 years ago,
so she's just lying in bed like that.
Aneurism
just paint all the time.
She's done is,
she's done from the,
here's a,
they gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years.
Yeah.
And it wasn't a good 12 years.
It wasn't a good 12 years.
It's your grandfather was getting zero action.
I'd probably do whatever you want it.
This is exactly what I was saying earlier.
[inaudible]
you can hide the fucking cannoli.
Is Ned fucking Beluga?
She's going to be hairy guy.
That fucking God goes.
She could,
oh,
she got a big fucking juicy guy.
Who
at the end of it,
that's when you know you're done.
When you hit the Gaga.
What I fucking do her,
my brother,
I don't know.
She's moaning because of the aneurism cause I'm hitting the gun.
Oh,
it's awful.
Poor Lady.
Oh,
it was rough.
It was rough,
man.
Let me get my ice.
Can't stop.
What do I get?
Allergies.
This is laughing.
I'm crying too,
man.
It's such douchey thing
at a time.
Thing is so douchey and I'm a more offended because I know so many of those
people.
I'm more offended if I was files a waspy guy and I grew up in Phoenix.
I wouldn't really be concentrating on these people.
But it's like being around like,
and knowing once you've escaped,
like,
oh,
and then you watch real housewives in New Jersey.
Like I wasn't wrong.
I wasn't,
I didn't miss this.
You people are fucking savages.
Okay.